salut pour ce jeudi du hors sujet je
voulais répondre un peu la question où
vous me demandez souvent si un
mentaliste arnaque les gens écouter les
autres je sais pas moi en tout cas non
somme paraît évident mais ça m'a donné
envie de vous parler d'un bep
l'arnacoeur je sais pas s'il était
mentaliste mais en tout cas il était
très malin puisque je vous parlais d'un
homme qui s'est retrouvé quarante sept
fois en prison pour des faits qui
étaient avérés qui a toujours été libéré
au bout d'un ou deux jours parce que les
victimes ne portait pas plainte contre
lui et sa plus belle arnaque c'est en
1925 puisque victor lustig a vendu la
tour eiffel
victor est né en 1890 en autriche
hongrie s'était pas une famille aisée
aisée c'était pas une famille non plus
dans le besoin dont qui lui toute
l'éducation qu'il fallait il a fait
toutes ses études il a brillamment passé
ses diplômes d'avocat mais le sting ne
voulait pas réussir comme tout le monde
ils voulaient gagner beaucoup d'argent
et très rapidement pour profiter de sa
jeunesse vers 19 ans est venu
s'installer à paris c'était en plein
dans la belle époque il a rapidement
trouvé un business qui lui convenait en
tout cas qui lui convenait pour l'époque
il est devenu proxénète donc il avait
deux jeunes femmes à son service
ça s'est très très mal passé puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas forcément violence était
parasitée par un gangsta il s'est pris
un gros coup de couteau dans le visage
et il a arrêté cette profession et
surtout il s'est dit comment je peux
gagner beaucoup d'argent
d'une manière pas très honnête mais sans
risquer d'être inquiétées et cette idée
là il va la tenir de nikki einstein
victor travailler sur des tournois de
poker quand je dis travailler c'est
qu'ils trichent et y récupérer des
petites mises ya un hashtag l'avait
repéré il a un peu pris sous son aile et
lui a donné des conseils lui a dit ce
qu'il faut absolument c'est que tu joues
contre des personnes et quand elles
perdent contre toi elles se disent c'est
de ma faute c'est de ma faute je n'avais
qu'à pas faire ça à partir du moment où
tu despentes la culpabilité sur la
personne que tu piges jeunes alors cette
personne ne t'en voudra pas en tout cas
pas au point de faire des représailles
contre toi et c'était super malin au
mode de réflexion lorsque le bateau de
croisière je vais peut-être pas précisé
sa sur lequel il avait rencontré ni qui
a accosté aux états unis ils y allaient
à boston et là il a commencé à appliquer
ça et il a continué ainsi remontée d
arnaque de plus en plus grosse jusqu'en
wipro un papier en-tête de la ville de
paris et y convoque les cinq plus gros
ferraille heure de paris il reçoit tous
les cinq dans un salon privé et leur
explique qu'il est mandaté par le
président de la république était
doumergue à l'époque pour vendre la tour
eiffel qui n'avait pu tellement
d'utilité en fait le président souhaite
s'en débarrasser mais ça coûterait très
cher a démonté donc il la vend au
ferrailleur qui fera la meilleure offre
et ce dernier devra évidemment la
démonter il ya une seule condition à
tout ça c'est que tout doit
c'était très discret jusqu'à la
signature de la vente ce qui paraît tout
à fait logique
victor les emmène visiter la tour eiffel
et alors là c'est très drôle l'histoire
raconte qu'il avait une petite carte
barré tricolore bleu blanc rouge qu'il
avait prévu aucun plan spécifique à ce
moment-là il y aller au culot c'est à
dire il a foncé en coupant toute la file
des touristes qui attendait pour la tour
eiffel il a foncé au guichet avec un
quart tricolore en disant ces personnes
là ma compagne et on l'a tout simplement
laisser passer parce qu'il a fait preuve
d'autorité de confiance en soi
personne n'a vérifié si sa carte était
vrai ou pas mais du coup ça a été un
très bon combine soeur pour les cinq
personnes qui la compagnie qui sont dit
ok tout est cohérent ils ont fait la
visite est une petite semaine après il a
commencé à recevoir des propositions
d'achat ou tout du moins il en a tout de
suite reçu une c'est celle de monsieur
poisson comme quoi parfois il ya des
prédispositions avec son nom c'est
monsieur poisson qui lui a envoyé la
première offre d'achat
la victoire a pas pris de risque qui lui
a tout de suite dit ok il lui donne
rendez vous dans le salon de
particuliers où s'étaient vus déjà à
l'hôtel crillon et se fait payer en bon
de la liberté qui était une monnaie d
échange tout à fait courante à l'époque
alors malheureusement on ne sait pas
combien il lui a vendu donc on sait pas
combien a proposé ferrailleurs tout ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y avait
forcément un gros pot de vin à côté
puisqu'à cette époque je suppose que ça
a changé aujourd'hui
mais à cette époque pour ce genre de
vente ou de marché il fallait forcément
gré c'est un peu la patte pour être sûr
d'avoir l'offre et le lendemain lui stig
partait de paris d'une manière plutôt
définitivement fin à la base définitif
et monsieur poisson s'est bien rendu
compte qu'ils s'étaient fait arnaquer et
c'est là où c'est très malin puisqu'il
n'a pas porté plainte pour pas qu'on se
moque de lui et qu'on le trouve ridicule
d'avoir cru qu'il pouvait acheter la
tour eiffel comme ça c'est la honte qui
l'empêchait de porter plainte
malheureusement ça n'a pas changé grand
chose à sa situation puisque la faire à
force est éventé ça c'est suez donc il a
été un peu la risée tout paris à ce
moment là pour vous ayez un petit peu
aussi la fin de l'histoire de l'us tig
il a été effectivement arrêté 47 fois à
chaque fois il a été relâché parce que
personne nous apporter plein de soi
parce que les personnes voulaient pas
paraître ridicule soit parce que ça
allait mais tu es dans le rôle du
méchant quelqu'un d'antipathie qu il
monte toujours ses plans dans ce sens là
pour s'en sortir
sauf la 48e fois où il un petit peu
déconné il a arnaqué un gros commerçants
à new york pour un spectacle qui l'a
jamais monté sauf qu'il avait pas
appliquer sa méthode le commerçant
n'avait aucune raison de ne pas porter
plainte contre lui et il s'est fait
gauler direction alcatraz où les décidé
en 1947
voilà l'histoire de
qui a vendu la tour eiffel j'espère que
cette histoire comme cette vidéo vous
aura plu si c'est le cas vous pouvez
également continuer à lire sur internet
en tapant victor l'ust il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui ont été créés sur
sa vie évidemment quand on est malin il
faut pas s'amuser à faire ce genre de
choses là et si vous avez appris deux
trois choses dans cette vidéo où au
moins si elle vous intéressez vous
pouvez sans arnaque me laissait un
délicat pouce en l'air
vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo
parce que je lis tous les commentaires
j'aime bien ça donc allez-y n'hésitez
pas vous pouvez aussi me mettre des
idées de choses que vous voudriez pour
les prochains hors sujet n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner également la chaîne
avant de partir parce que le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
ce qui veut dire que demain c'est la
moitié du défi donc rendez vous demain à
17 heures ciao